members we're now back on
live stream so i would like to welcome
back
members of the public uh who are
rejoining us
for the completion of the meeting
um councillor wooden
thank you uh chairman um chairman at
this point
i will be moving uh the recommendations
in the report but before i do so
i would like to thank members officers
and our partners
for what has been a useful debate this
evening
there has been a lot for us to consider
and this is a big decision for members
tonight
but i want also to remind members that
this has always been a member-led
project they can have confidence in that
members have been involved in it from
day one
myself the investment board and
colleagues from the member working group
have been working closely throughout the
procurement process
working with officers as those
negotiations have been going on
and taking advice and support from a
team of external
professional advisors some of whom you
have heard from tonight
i am satisfied that the issues
identified by members
on 19th of may have been adequately
addressed
and that the issues raised by members
tonight have also been comprehensively
covered
but i am keen to ensure that the whole
council feels not just
reassured but he's as committed and
excited as i am
by this opportunity because this is an
exciting moment for the district
an important opportunity to take a
decisive step
in the way the council manages its
estate
this project will regenerate key parts
of our district's towns
in rochford and raleigh and create new
community assets
which offer better and more cost
effective facilities for our residents
it is a balance of risk and reward
this project is not risk-free no project
is risk-free
market conditions can change and affect
capital receipts
similarly costs can rise through
unknowns
and kobit 19 introduces further
uncertainty
but every business and every
organization is facing these challenges
they certainly are not unique to this
council
officers and advisers have constructed a
program
that mitigates these risks and provides
the council
with stop go decision points which
ensure
it remains in control and fully
understands any changes in funding
requirements
members in our business plan that we
approved only back in february this year
we said that our values were customer
focused
maximizing potential proactive
innovative this project is
all of those things our business plan
priorities
are to be financially sustainable and
maximize our assets
to enable communities and intervene
early to support
and invest in those communities this
project does all of those things
too chairman i therefore commend the
recommendations
to this council there is a suggested
amendment at page 1.0 page
1.2 um which just adds clarity to the
word
mill but i will take your advice on how
you want to deal with that
thank you chairman chairman i'm happy to
send that proposition thank you
councillor steptoe and thank you
councilor
wharton um
mason you've indicated you wish to speak
yes thank you mr chairman in view of the
night and the lateness of the hour i'm
going to be very brief
we have had a lengthy private
debate unfortunately that's not allowed
the fears that have been expressed
um i still feel this is reckless and
premature
and whilst councillor woodson might be
satisfied i'm afraid
i am not satisfied that this council
should be taking this activity this
commitment at this point in time thank
you
thank you councillor mrs uh mason
um councillor hawkway
thank you chairman um i'll just um like
to
um to state for the record and and in
public as well
um that um i
i would like to um hope
that uh the optimism that uh
councillor wootton has expressed in his
uh statement um
uh comes to fruition um however
um as stated by council mason there has
been a number of
issues raised in the
private uh part of this meeting uh for
there to be
some major concerns uh going forward
with a number of different conditions
and therefore i i do support
councilmation's view that uh
perhaps um uh this is a little bit
premature but
um i think thank you for allowing me to
speak and to
councillor hookway um in response to
that i would uh
respond to say that we have had a full
debate
on both parts of the uh session
this evening and a conclusion
obviously um will be made
thank you members right i shall now go
to a recommendation 14.1
mrs carter no it's too late
um uh counselor sorry i'll now go to
recommendation
14.1 it's been proposed by council
wooden
and seconded by uh councillor mike
steptoe
i shall now do a roll call please
indicate
whether you wish to wish a recorded vote
for or against or wish to abstain
when i call your name counselor mrs
belton
no recorded vote for councillor mrs
butcher
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
four councillor canal
no i'm for thank you councillor
mr carter no recorded
m4 councillor mrs carter
thank you chair i did have my hand up
i'm not very happy about this at all and
i like to make that quite clear
i'd like a recorded vote please and i am
against myself no recorded vote and
four councillor fd no recorded vote and
four thank you chairman
councillor eves recorded vote and
abstain
thank you councillor mrs gooding no
recorded vote
m4 thank you chairman mr hazelwood
no record is voting for thank you
councillor hawkway
recorded vote and against councillor
hudson
no recorded votes and for the
recommendation
council mrs lumley no and four
thank you councillor mrs mason thank you
mr chairman
recorded vote requested and
against the recommendation council mrs
mcpherson
no recorded vote chairman and four thank
you
now it's lumerick no and four
councillor milne no and four
councillor newport recorded vote and
against
councillor mrs pavlin
no i'm for thank you
yeah so mrs rowe thank you chairman now
and
for councillor mrs shaw
no and four councillor mr shaw
no and four thank you chairman now mr
smith
no recorded vote and four thank you
thank you council sparing
no and four thank you council stanley
uh recorded vote and against
council steptoe no and four
council award no and fortune
that's the web thank you chairman no and
for council western no i'm for chairman
thank you
williams
thank you chairman that's no and for
outside wilson
thank you chair yes for recorded vote
and against the recommendation
thank you council woodson no and four
thank you chairman
thank you members of
oh
members there will be a recorded vote
there are four
the 25 members four six against and one
abstention so that has been carried
thank you members
members recommendations numbers two to
seven
are to be noted um i shall
take those on block uh but for the sake
of
clarity chairman
chairman if i can just remind you there
has been some slight amendments to 14.2
so chairman if you could read out 14.2
with the amendments that would be
um that would be ideal thank you
um thank you for that i was going to
read out the amended um
recommendation to anyway if i can
i shall take recommendations two to
seven
in block as they are for noting um
and if members i would assume that
members are in agreement
unless they click on their raised hand
icon
so this is a recommendations two to
seven
and for the sake of clarity members i
shall read out the amended
recommendation to paragraph 14.2
it now reads as follows to note that the
draft conditional
sale contract for the mill arts and
event center site
is yet to be drafted but will be in the
form of a
csci bracket to deal with the element of
the mill arts and event center site
that will transfer to the developer
close bracket
with the development obligations from
schedule 1 of the oda
bracket to do with the community
facilities that the developer
will be providing for the council close
bracket
and to delegate the final completion of
this document
to the assistant director assets and
commercial in consultation with leader
of the council
on the best on the basis set out in this
report
so we are voting on that and
on uh recommendations
two to seven anybody who disagrees
please
raise your hand icon so you've got no
you've got nobody with the raised hand
so that's noted uh
there is nobody indicating their
disagreement members they have been
agreed thank you
members i shall now take a
recommendation eight
paragraph 14.8
that the appointment of the officers and
leader of the council sorry
sorry chairman you've got a hand up for
mrs uh carter
where to who mrs carter
councillor mrs carter's got a hand up um
yes i have thank you council western um
can i just send my apologies i need to
leave please
i've got to get up for work in the
morning
as i was saying i shall now take
recommendation eight um
paragraph 14.8 that the appointment of
the officers and the leader of the
council to the partnership board be on
the basis are set out
in appendix 10.
members normal roll call procedures
councilor mrs belton
no recorded vote n4 thank you
councillor mrs butcher
thank you no recorded vote
for councillor canal
no and four thank you chad thank you
councillor mr
carter no recorded m4
thank you myself no recorded vote and
four
councillor fd no recorded voting for
chairman
thank you thank you councillor eves
councillor mrs gooding no recorded vote
and four thank you
councillor hazelwood no record is voted
for thank you councillor hawkway
at recorded vote and against thank you
councillor hudson no recorded votes and
for the motion
council mrs lumley no and four
thank you councillor mrs mason
recorded vote against councillor mrs
mcpherson
no recorded vote and four thank you
chairman
yeah that's the merrick oh and four
thank you councillor milne no recorded
vote
and four council newport
recorded and against thank you
councillor mrs pavlin
no i'm four announcer mrs rowe
thank you chairman now and for council
mr shaw
no i'm four thank you mr shaw
no i'm four thank you thank you
councillor smith
no recorded vote and four council
sparing
no and four answers stanley
we can't be vote and against thank you
thank you
no and four thank you council ward
no in four thank you chairman webb
thank you chairman no and for council
western
uh no for chairman thank you sir
williams
thanks chairman no and for council
wilson
uh yes for recorded vote and against
recommendation thank you
council woodson no i'm four thank you
chairman
thank you members i'll come back
thank you members there's no recorded
vote
25 votes for recommendation
six against no abstentions that
recommendation members have been
approved
i shall now take a recommendation nine
paragraph 14.
chairman you're ignoring my hand
i can't see your hand well you need to
look at it
or whoever's assisting you needs to help
thank you councillor mrs mason
thank you i would like my vote against
recorded um thank you
thank you that will be done thank you
members we now take a recommendation 9
paragraph 14.9
which reads as follows to appoint the
assistant director
bracket assets in commercial close
bracket as a council senior
representative officer
for the purposes of this project and to
delegate to the officers appointed to
the partnership board decision-making
powers
to manage the operational day-to-day
business of the asset delivery
program and again normal procedures
uh voting regards to the roll call
councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote and for chairman thank
you councillor mrs butcher
no recorded vote m4 thank you
that's the canal no and for
chairman councillor mr carter
no and four thank you thank you myself
no recorded vote and four
councillor fd mary caldey voting for
thank you chairman
thank you councillor eves vote and
abstain
thank you
no recorded vote and four thank you
that's the hazelwood
no one call thank you councillor hawkway
no and fall thank you councillor hudson
uh no a recorded vote and four
also mrs lamley no and four
councillor mrs mason thank you mr
chairman a recorded vote
against the recommendation and may i
have my vote recorded should it not be a
recorded vote thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson no and four
thank you chairman
yes lumerick no and four
councilor milne known for thank you mr
chairman
that's the newport recorded and abstain
counselor pavlin
four thank you mrs rowe
thank you chairman no aimed for
councillor mr score
no one four thank you thank you
councillor mr shaw
no i'm four thank you alexa smith
no recorded vote and four thank you
council sparing
no and four counts of stan lee
he called it and abstained thank you
yeah this is step toe oh and four
hours award no one's four
thank you chairman thank you council
webb thank you chairman
no and four please nelson is it western
i
thank you council williams mr
chairman no and for council wilson
all recorded vote and abstain chairman
and mr
council woodson no i'm four thank you
chairman
members there'll be no recorded vote
there are 26
members voting for one against and four
abstentions
that recommendation members have been
approved
members i shall now go to recommendation
10 paragraph 1410
um to invite the council to appoint
membership of the partnership panel
for the municipal year 2020 stroke 21 on
a pro writer basis
has set out in appendix 11.
come in there please yes
councilwood chairman thank you very much
indeed
um on item 14.10
um all leaders were asked to put their
nominations in and i know the
item says to invite council to appoint
membership
uh do we know who the members are i
certainly submitted the conservative
groups
nominations by the allotted time
yesterday
yes um i can confirm that the
conservative group members are
counsellors mrs belton councillors mrs
gooding councillor milner council
steptoe
the green group of nominated councillor
wilson
um council newport are you able to
advise the council of the liberal
democrats nominee
chairman it's my understanding that the
nominations
um aren't specifically a name but
and can you just confirm that we can
substitute on this
panel
angela law can you um uh comment on that
please as to whether substitutes will be
allowed
just just checking chairman
we're checking council newport but we
just still need a nomination from you
yeah we will uh nominate councillor
chris stanley
thank you um and i suggest angelo comes
back to you in
on that question after this meeting um
how's the mrs mason are you able to
advise the council of the rocha district
residence nominee
yes of course i am mr chairman um we
just felt it was more appropriate to be
done in
council the uh nomination is councillor
neil hookway thank you right
members um the
voting again will be done by roll call
of names
normal procedure applies
councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote n4 thank you thank you
councilman mrs butcher thank you
chairman no recorded vote and four thank
you
councillor canal
no recorded vote for
councillor mr carter no recorded and
four thank you myself no recorded vote
on four
councillor fd thank you chairman no he
called you voting for
thank you councillor eves no and four
thank you
thank you councillor mrs gooding
no recorded vote and four thank you
chair
councillor hazelwood no one for
thank you council hookway uh no recorded
vote and four
thank you councillor hudson no recorded
vote
before thank you councillor mrs lumley
no and four thank you council mrs mason
thank you mr chairman no recorded vote
and for the motion
thank you council mrs [ __ ] ferguson
uh no and four thank you chairman thank
you councilman
no and four thank you councillor milne
no and for councillor newport
no and four thank you councillor mrs
paintlin
uh no and four yes and mrs rowe
thank you chairman no i'm four yeah so
mrs shaw
thank you no and four councillor mr shaw
no and four yeah mr smith
no recorded vote and four thank you
counselor sparing
no and four now sir stan lee
no recording vote and four counts of
steptoe
no and four thank you council ward
yeah sorry about that chairman uh known
for
thank you councilman mrs weston
uh known for chairman thank you yes sir
webb
thank you chairman no and four thank you
council williams
thank you chairman no and for
councillor wilson thank you chairman no
and for
thank you council woodson no i'm four
thank you chairman
thank you members i'll come back
that's unanimously approved and no
recorded vote thank you
chairman if i may chairman
you're not mute you're muted angela law
yes please yes i just want to come back
on a question from councilman newport
um yes i see no reason why we can't have
substitutes on the
partnership panel is a forum for
communication and engagement so
um i will i will make those in the terms
of reference
thank you angelo um your points
no to counselor newport
right i now take um
a recommendation 11 paragraph 14.11
to approve the drawdown from the hard
stroke soft infrastructure reserve of 70
thousand pounds to fund additional
program costs
the detailed and resource implications
bracket
section 11 closed bracket
and again voting will be done by a roll
call
normal
normal seizure applies counsellor mrs
belton
thank you no recorded and for thank you
councillor mrs butcher
thank you you know recorded and for
thank you a councillor canal
recorded an abstain chair thank you
mr carter no recorded m4
thank you myself now recorded and four
councillor fd thank you chairman no
recording and four
thank you councillor eves thought he'd
vote and definitely against
councillor mrs gooding a recorded vote
and four thank you chair
councillor hazelwood no record his vote
and abstain
councillor hawkway recorded vote and
against
council hudson no recorded vote and four
councillor mrs lumley no and for
councillor mrs mason thank you mr
chairman
a recorded vote and definitely against
councilman mrs mcpherson
no and for announcement
no and four thank you councillor milne
no and for councillor newport
recorded anna against your counselor mrs
pavlin
no i'm four thank you you know so mrs
rowe
thank you chairman no and four thank you
councillor mr shaw
i'm sorry sorry no and four thank you
council mr shaw
no i'm full thank you council smith
no recorded vote and four council
sparing
no and four council stanley
recording and the games thank you
council steptoe
oh and four thank you council award
no n4 chairman thank you thank you
council webb
thank you chairman no and for please
thank you
thank you council mrs weston
councilman sorry chairman uh nothing for
chairman sorry
thank you council williams chairman no
end for
eliza wilson or a recorded vote
and the gates chairman and council
wooden
no i'm for thank you chairman thank you
members
okay
there will be a recorded vote there were
23 members of
four six against and two abstentions
and so that recommendation members has
been approved and members that concludes
the business and the recommendations
i would like to express my thanks for
all speakers today particularly our
guests who came along to support
supporters today and thank everybody for
attending the meeting
and for their patience and forbearing
i declare the meeting closed at
10 55. thank you very much
thank you chairman thank you good night
thank you
thank you